-My next guests are the stars
of the biggest television show
in the world, "Squid Game."
It is streaming now on Netflix.
Here are Lee Jung-jae,
Park Hae-soo,
Wi Ha-Joon, and Jung Hoyeon!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Welcome! Yes! Yes!
Welcome, welcome, welcome!
Welcome to "The Tonight Show."
Thank you so much
for being here.
-[ Speaking native language ]
-Thank you.
-Thank you for having us.
-This is a big deal.
I just want to start.
Jung-jae, you're the first one
we meet in the show,
and you're so charming
and, like, lovable.
We're rooting for you.
I know that
you're famous in Korea
for mostly playing villains
in a movie.
How can that face be a villain?
You're so friendly and likable.
Can you tell everyone
what "Squid Game" is about?
-[ Speaking native language ]
-It's frightening.
It is shocking.
But it's also really beautiful,
and right now it is number one
on Netflix in 90 countries.
[ Cheers and applause ]
It is bigger than --
Uh, Hae-soo, when did you
realize the show became so big?
-Right now.
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Right now?
-[ Speaking native language ]
Yeah, right now.
I want to meet Jimmy...
[ Audience awws ]
-That's what I'm talking about.
See? This is...
That's my man.
I love you. Come on.
Oh. I'm so happy.
Ha-Joon, what do you think
people around the world
are connecting to?
-Ohh...
[ Speaking native language ]
-Yeah, it is --
it's bizarre how --
the combo of that.
The children's game,
but also people desperate
kind of to just change
their life and get money.
And they'll do -- And it starts
with the creepiest doll I've --
And I have to show you,
for people who haven't seen.
I got this sent over to us.
This came in the mail.
[ Laughter ]
This came in the mail for me.
Yeah, thank you so much.
Wait. No.
If you haven't seen this...
Wait. Watch this. This is --
So, this is what --
They played
Red Light, Green Light,
but this giant doll
looks at them, okay?
And she says, "Green light,"
and her head is turned around.
When she says, "Red light,"
she turns around,
and her eyes are cameras.
And if you move, you get shot.
[ Laughs ]
But -- I know.
But, also, this robot
is based on a character, right?
From Korean textbooks.
Like, when kids are growing up,
you know who this --
Who is this?
Who is this psycho robot?
[ Laughter ]
-When we were at the school,
there were, like, characters.
One is a boy,
and one is the girl.
The boy's name was Chulsoo,
and the girl's name
was Younghee.
And she's the one.
-Whew. Yeah.
Jung-jae,
this show is pretty dark,
but your character
is optimistic and funny.
And I was just wondering,
is there anything
that didn't make it to the show
that was --
or maybe things that were in the
show that were improvised?
-[ Laughs ]
[ Speaking native language ]
-I remember that scene. The --
It's in the first episode.
No spoilers.
I'm not giving any spoilers
tonight, so everyone knows.
Hae-soo, you became a dad
the day "Squid Game" premiered.
Is that correct?
[ Applause ]
-[ Speaking native language ]
-Baby Squid.
[ Applause ]
-Yeah! Little Baby Squid!
How cute! Come on!
I want to show everyone
a clip from the show.
This is "Squid Game."
Take a look.
-♪ In other words ♪
♪ Darling, kiss me ♪
♪ Fill my heart with song ♪
♪ And let me sing forever more ♪
♪ You are all I long for ♪
♪ All I worship and adore ♪
♪ In other words ♪
♪ Please be true ♪
[ Music stops ]
-[ Breathing sharply ]
-Ohh!
[ Cheers and applause ]
He saved you! I love it!
The cast of "Squid Game,"
everybody!
The show is streaming now
on Netflix.
"Squid Game" is all about
playing childhood games,
so I thought we could have
some fun with that.
You're about to face off
against each other
in the "Tonight Show
Schoolyard Games."
Here we go.
-♪ Schoolyard Games, ooh, yeah ♪
-Now, the games will now begin.
All will play,
but only one can win.
Round one, Slapsies.
[ Dramatic music plays ]
[ Applause ]
This is the game where you do
this over each other's hands.
You can kind of fake out,
but if you fake out
and you flinch and move all
the way back, you slap the hand.
But if you can do it
fast enough and just go like --
wa-psh!
That's Slapsies, yeah.
Yeah.
It might not be called that.
We might have made up
the name "Slapsies."
But that's the game.
Jung-jae, Hae-soo,
you're up first.
On your mark.
Get set.
-[ Speaking native language ]
-Go.
♪♪
-Whoa!
-Wow.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
[ Bell dings ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Hae-soo, you won that one.
[ Laughs ]
Not at the whole game.
Okay.
Ha-Joon, Hoyeon, you're up next.
♪♪
-[ Speaking native language ]
-Okay.
I want to...
-Three, two, one.
♪♪
Yeah! Oh, my God! Yeah!
First try!
-[ Speaking native language ]
-All right. That means we go
to the final round right here.
Hae-soo, Hoyeon,
you are up against each other.
Yeah. Good --
Best of luck. Yeah.
This is what I'm talking about.
-All right. One, two, three.
♪♪
[ Bell dings ]
-[ Laughs ]
Are you okay?
-Congratulations.
It is time for the next round.
And things aren't
going to get any easier.
Because you're about to play
one of the most dangerous games
of all --
Rock, Paper, Scissors.
[ Dramatic music plays ]
Jung-jae, Hae-soo,
you are up first.
Rock, Paper, Scissors.
Whenever you're ready,
you can go.
-[ Speaking native language ]
-[ Bell dings ]
-Jung-jae!
Jung-jae is the winner
of that one.
Ha-Joon, Hoyeon, you're up now.
-Both:
Rock, paper, scissor!
-Okay.
-There's two scissors.
-Rock, paper, scissor!
-No!
-[ Bell dings ]
-Here we go!
Now, Jung-jae, Ha-Joon,
you guys have to go head-to-head
rock, paper, scissors
to see who the winner
of this match is.
Here we go.
I know. Look at this.
Whew. Gear up.
Mentally focus.
When you're ready. Yeah.
-[ Speaking native language ]
-[ Bell dings ]
-Oh, yes!
That's what I'm talking about
right there!
Ha-Joon! Congratulations, bud!
[ Cheers and applause ]
All right. We've now reached
the final round.
This determines
the winner of everything.
But before we play, each of you
must pick a number
between 1 and 4.
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
-I will go...number two.
-Three.
-Okay.
-Four.
-One.
-Yeah, you have no choice.
You have no choice.
You're one. Okay, here we go.
Now that your numbers are
locked in, the game may begin.
It is time
for Egg and Spoon Race.
[ Dramatic music plays ]
But not all spoons
are created equal.
The number you choose
determines your spoon.
Please take the spoon
that matches your number.
-Ah.
-What is number two?
-Three.
-Number two!
Yeah! Number two!
-Yeah, that's a good one.
-[ Laughs ] Four. One.
-Oh, no. Oh, no.
One, you got --
You have a tough --
[ Laughs ] Oh, my gosh.
Oh, no. Oh, no. Okay.
Oh, no. All right.
When you're ready, take your
places and get ready to race.
The first person
to cross the finish line
with an intact egg
is the winner.
On your mark. Get set.
-On my mark.
-Go!
-Aah!
-Ohh! Hey! All right.
Jung-jae. Jung-jae, you get it.
But you know what?
You're all winners.